let's talk about what's going on here in
Florida because again I think this is
the blueprint for a future America it is
the blueprint that every state should be
modeling and you know what even
Democrats in Florida are realizing how
good we got it so this is the former
Democrat mayor of Miami Beach Philip
Levine on CNN saying yeah Floridians get
it and and they've had it with the Dems
and there's something good going on here
truthfully I think it's too little too
late and President Biden coming here is
fantastic but unfortunately the
Democratic party of Florida has been in
a semi-conscious coma for a long period
now and I don't think a week out that's
going to do much if anything whatsoever
I mean think of what's going on as far
as the messaging Florida's been hitting
on all cylinders and I'm a Democrat
telling you this what a Floridian is
concerned about they're concerned about
inflation they don't pin that to the
current Administration in Florida they
pin that to Washington to the Democratic
party they're concerned about
immigration they're concerned about
crime think about what's going on in our
country right now people are getting
mugged they're getting mugged on the
city streets but they're also getting
mugged when they go to the grocery
stores so that is something that they're
pinning on the Democratic party in
Washington they're not pinning it on the
Republican party that's controlling the
State of Florida so I don't believe that
will have any impact if any at all at
this point and so late in the game
warmer Democrat Miami Beach mayor by the
way we have a Republican mayor in Miami
right now mayor Francis Suarez who I
interviewed I've interviewed him a
couple times but one of them was about
two three weeks ago Miami now is the
fittest city in the United States it is
the healthiest city in the United States
I think it is the least crime for a big
city in the United States we are
bringing in all sorts of tech companies
businesses exploding they're doing
incredible amounts of construction we
have buildings going up everywhere the
roads are being redone it's like it's
all working here and why is it all
working here because the people
thirty thousand extra people voted for
Ron DeSantis instead of Andrew Gilliam
and these last couple years Ron DeSantis
grew into the role you know sometimes
sometimes people are born to lead
sometimes people kind of stumble into it
I don't know which is which with this
anthis but he clearly has become the guy
that we need at the moment